- [Voiceover] This is the Hyacinth Macaw.
It's big, it's bright,
and it's vulnerable to lots of threats.
The largest parrot by length in the world,
it can grow up to 40 inches.
Their feathers are a
beautiful striking blue.
Unfortunately, their
good looks have made them
highly desirable in the illegal pet trade,
fetching upwards of $10,000.
Hyacinths are native to
Central and South America,
primarily in the scrublands
at the outskirts of the rainforest.
It is an affectionate bird,
but its powerful beak carries
over 200 pounds of
pressure per square inch,
strong enough to crack a coconut.
Their diet in the wild
consists mostly of nuts
from native palms.
Beyond being a hot
commodity in the pet trade,
Hyacinths are watching their habitat
get converted to farmland,
leaving them less and less space to live.
This is the Hyacinth Macaw.
(dramatic music)